i don't have to [ __ ] clean his dirty
dishes i don't have to see his [ __ ]
pube hairs all over the bathroom
he's this polished he's wearing like
nice work clothes or whatever he's
always shaving he always smells good i'm
not getting the [ __ ] farting on a
saturday afternoon
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to big mood
today hello we have the regular standard
crew myself jessica i am regular nikki
just plain old gina
i'm tiff all right we have pregnant we
still have pregnancies
still pregnant but very tiny belly by
the time you see this i should be a lot
bigger like double the size but uh we
filmed these in advance so wait
wednesday when's due date again due
dates february 25th oh oh oh tomorrow's
isaac's birthday by the way
happy birthday birthday
he is a full-on team
well today um i wanted to talk about
workplace affairs because you know i
recently started working gina has a nine
to five now so you guys are fantasizing
we're fantasizing there's some hotties
in the office i work with a bunch of
nerds man i know
yeah they could be affairs you have a
there's gonna be hotness there's a cute
guy in your office i met my husband
through work
working with you yeah he is a nurse and
he's pretty nerdy
yeah so um i mean no i'm kidding though
like i'm not trying to glorify workplace
affairs but um i did want to talk about
it because i found an article on the
psychology of workplace affairs and i
wanted to kind of dig in a little and
then also i found this other article
about
cheating and like how to deal with
cheating like with your partner like
what not to say i was like oh this is
kind of interesting what not to say yeah
like if you cheat yeah that's weird like
how to get away with cheating how to get
away with it but like a common thing
that people say when they bring their
cheating revelation to their partner
that's actually more damaging oh
but that'll be like later in the episode
so stick around like if you're going to
uh cheating these are things you
shouldn't see because it'll make a lot
more sense or this is not a waiting
here's how not to die yeah yeah pretty
much
like so i had to cheat because our sex
life was so yeah so what happened was i
was all like this and she fell she fell
on me he fell right in me yeah
i was like no stop yeah
there were people too um
that were interested in hearing us talk
about like work husbands or like yeah
okay well we can touch on that i can
touch on that too a little bit firstly
because i guess that kind of leads into
like how you get to cheating yeah and
why your partner might be jealous and
then the other partner that has the work
husband's like don't worry about it but
then they should have been worried about
it so
i
i guess i kind of have a little bit of
an experience with this because i felt
like i kind of had a work husband but he
wasn't really because he was also
actually married and i would never i
would never specifically pick a married
man to cheat with but i just felt like i
was so close to this person because we
worked together on all of our jobs yeah
and like we would have so much fun on
all of our jobs too and i kind of felt
like when i knew that i was going to be
placed on a job with him yeah i would be
so excited yeah i was like yeah this is
going to be fun but um there was a point
where i realized i was like oh yeah he
actually he is married like he is
married so i would have to keep
sometimes reminding myself that he is
married like you can't do you think
about him in any other way but do you
think that's bad to have a crush on
someone like cause
i don't know i'm bad about that no but
if you can't control yourself control
you need to know yourself exactly i mean
like obviously
you're not gonna go try to have sex with
him i mean that's that's [ __ ] up but
then but like having a crush like
getting excited to see someone is like
sometimes i have that with girls too i
mean but i mean there's a little bit
more
with a guy because there's like this
chemistry but
i mean it probably is what you're
feeling is chemistry yeah but i don't
know if i i'm i'm mixed on how i feel
about that like i don't know if i'd
necessarily think it's bad like because
knowing that you're never going to act
on it yeah
or allow anything to cross a line i
guess it's like it's nice to have people
you're excited to work with or be around
when you talk about being excited and
like being around is that the same thing
and then like to label them as a work
husband i don't think i would ever say
that out loud yeah yeah yeah but like to
yourself yeah but like does there need
to be a level of like
attracted to like attractiveness like
that you're physically attracted to them
i would say probably another world you
would
how i kind of felt because i was i
thought like to myself with my quote
unquote fake work husband that he never
knew i felt this way about yeah
that like i was attracted to like i i
remember one time i actually had a sex
dream about him yeah um but of course
you know i wake up and i have to like
wash my [ __ ] eyeballs out yeah like
you know oh and just say the [ __ ]
hail mary and like let that [ __ ] go
because it's like absolutely never never
never never territory never territory
but i feel like you can't kind of you
can't help the feeling part yeah the
action part absolutely i cannot be that
person but the feeling part i feel like
i don't feel like i can help it like um
i i know that before steve and i were
together we were both in serious
relationships and
um when we're in relationships we have
like blinders like we're not attracted
but when you're acting with people um i
mean maybe the entertainment industry is
different but like we would play
boyfriend and girlfriend sometimes and
when you're acting with someone uh and
this has happened in other movies and um
stuff that i've been worked on too but
when i'm acting as their girlfriend you
have to create in your brain a whole
history like that you guys are a couple
and like make it real and sometimes
there is chemistry there and then it
makes work easier and it's exciting to
go there and you guys have a good banter
and and with steve and i we always had
great banter like no matter what and i
didn't think of him as like i didn't go
home and fantasize about having sex with
him at all yeah um i mean i was very
happy with my boyfriend um and he seemed
happy in his relationship too but it was
really exciting
when i found out i was working with him
or that we were in a scene together or
that we were gonna get to improv
together because i knew that like it was
going to be fun yeah and that's the type
of person that i like hanging out with
but your story's a little different
because you actually cause that but
that's the only thing yeah and it wasn't
when we were together it was just like
then i was single first i got dumped by
well actually my boyfriend cheated on me
um so we broke up and i was devastated i
couldn't even think about kissing
another person like for the longest time
i i couldn't even think about
another
being being in like his place but um i
had i still had to work so i still went
and filmed stuff and steve would be on
some of the shoots and i kind of started
having a crush on him and i didn't i was
i would tell my girlfriend who knew both
of us i was like okay i'm only gonna
tell you this but like
i would never do anything but
i want someone that's like stevie he's
like so fun to hang out with and like i
just feel like we get each other we have
the same sense of humor we see the world
the same way and it helped me like mold
what i wanted to find and i've talked
about this so many times before but i
like he created the standard for me i
never thought he'd be single ever
and then his girlfriend dumped him
randomly out of nowhere i mean they were
having a bad time she was always talking
about doing that but i never thought she
actually would and then she did
and my girlfriend that i had been
telling her about um she's like what if
he they she broke up with him and then
like you're gonna go on a date and then
marriage i was like i'm not gonna date
this guy for at least six months
and then like within two weeks we were
like boyfriend oh my gosh
well that was clearly meant to be yeah
but i think for most work husbands it's
something that will never actually
happen no or like you know you change
jobs and then you just forget that
person even existed like time goes by
nothing has ever happened i mean have
you had a crush on anyone that you've
worked with before gina um i remember
when i worked at the cheesecake factory
when i was like 19 i had a crush on the
bartender yeah even like that yeah but
then even then i never wanted to date or
hook up with anyone that i work with
because i just know how messy that can
get
uh and personally i don't i just don't
do i don't prefer it and if i were to
have a work husband he would have to be
like
super gay like super gay super gay
that's what i kind of wanted to ask
about too because i'm like i
i have had like work guy friend like
best friends that i'm like yeah i'm
excited to work with him like i'm
looking forward to the time because i
also had a gay husband i also had a gay
best friend husband well this guy wasn't
gay
yeah that's why i'm asking because i
think it's different because
i have never felt any sexual attraction
to my work guy best friends like so i'm
like yeah were they my work husbands
like i've never had
a crush on anyone i have ever worked
i've had both so i mean i've like had oh
um i've had a mic
like for example like going to
uh
even like jk i know how their
personalities are and it's fun but it's
not the same like it's like they're kind
of like there's not one person that
you're like i can't wait to go see that
person no no they're more like it's like
more like a brother relationship
but then i've worked on like
films before
where the
i've had a crush on like
a cast member but not in a way where i'd
go home and like
fantasize about them just like i'm
excited to go see them and i'm excited
to like be in a scene with them and
because you know it's going to be fun
and yeah
and it's like kind of flirty but no
one's going to do anything yeah like
i've never flirted at work
like i'm even thinking about like
because i worked at jk for so many years
i'm not even counting jk as my work
history because they were like family
yeah but like working at the hospitals
or like at my early jobs i never crushed
on anyone that worked there no like i
did have other people like at the
hospital for example there would be like
guys that worked at different
departments like they didn't want to
work directly with me
and we would just be in passing like
saying hi i would be like oh i kind of
have like a tiny little crush on him but
we didn't even oh yeah that's like
really nice we didn't bond it was just
like only like no
never had it yeah it's like a partner
it's like a like you guys get each other
and like
they compliment you yeah they're a part
of your work life yeah they're like a
balance
sexually attracted to whoever i have had
connections like that with at work it's
weird because it's like it's not sexual
for me per se it's like not necessarily
like just like a car like a bunny
yeah like where you're like oh i'm just
excited like like if you could picture
them like if you could picture yourself
kissing them like that like if like if
it could get into that category i've
never had that category
i think you can but it's not so
like blatant blatant yeah you know
you're not like maybe even if it goes
that far you get kind of like oh i don't
know
but then you just still really like that
person yeah so you know how you spend
all of your personal life with your
husband you spend 40 50 60 hours
depending on your work
flow with
this person so that kind of is like this
is my husband in my room it's like
regularly like that this is my husband
yeah because i spend 50 of hours a week
with this person and it's almost that's
why the husband part comes in because
it's all you're not always thinking
about [ __ ] and kissing your husband
like every single day especially after
you've been together for like 10 years
right like but they're just so much in
your life
and you know they're like that partner
part it's like the same thing but like
in a different half of your life but you
guys are a little different because your
work life and your home life is all the
same
my current workout
same boring
um i think for me it's like i've never i
this is my first day job in like a
decade so
i never really had like a work crush
because i think when it comes to work i
have like a barrier or it's just like
this this this hard boundary it's like
you just haven't had the right guy yeah
exactly
because i have that same boundary yeah
me too and it would never cross like
nothing would ever happen yeah yeah but
it just is exciting to see there's a guy
with enough charisma you work with him
every day for [ __ ] like two years
on g4 we have kasim who is a very yeah
and he's funny but it's just like i
can't imagine myself oh well yeah you
don't know it's not it's like you don't
picture like yesterday you could be your
work husband it could be no not even
like we're all because i think we all
came together as a group yeah so we work
and we function as a group yeah if
anything so i can't even i think there's
just not enough there has to be some
sort of chemistry there for yeah to be
like this is my work husband oh this is
also not something you would ever tell
anyone
when i had this with i would never
[ __ ] admit it not like in a million
years whatever i can say anything i
think i only told like one two one or
two people yeah um i told
sky john so shout out to tipsy bartender
so uh he had asked if i would ever date
a youtuber because he was trying to hook
me up with some other youtuber and i was
like there's only one youtuber i'd ever
think about but it'll never happen
because he's with somebody yeah they're
gonna get married and he's like who and
so i told him and then he forever
remembered that
that's so funny that's the only he's
like you're the only one yeah goes to
your wedding yeah well he was invited
but he was in vegas oh forget sky
maybe i just wasn't in the right
environment
like working in restaurants and then i
worked at an old restaurants are perfect
for the restaurants yeah yeah that's a
lot of like actual like [ __ ] actual
food
there was one where that was really hot
no but we
there wasn't like a real bond like no
it's like a real bond yeah there's
actually a really good king of queens
episode about this i love king of queens
i haven't seen that show in forever it's
my favorite i have the whole box there
you recently watch it you big nerd such
a nerd well i wanted a marriage like
theirs yeah and hey manifesting is real
yeah um so there's so carrie works at a
a law firm and she's an assistant and um
and
her husband kevin james his name's doug
in the in the show he comes and visits
her because he has a he's a ups driver
and so he goes and drops off a package
at her work and she's like oh my god now
my real husband and my work husband are
here and
or some one of her co-workers says that
oh carrie it's your work husband and
your real husband and then he's like a
work husband yeah and it's this whole
episode
it's really funny yeah if i ever went to
my dad's place and like find out he has
a work wife and she better be a raging
oh yeah she's dead she's dead yeah
she needs to be a raging lesbian like a
stud like all right so okay so why do
you feel that way
let's dig into that yeah
i don't know i think it's weird in a
sense like you guys can be friends and
co-workers but if you call
i don't know because i feel like wife is
my word right me you know like that
what if it's not acknowledged like they
like no one would ever say it out loud
and she doesn't call him that but they
have that bond they have that thing
not everyone's dying is
so this kind of ties in i wasn't here
for this episode but a while back stacy
was here and you guys had an episode
about can guys and girls be friends and
while i have some mixed opinions on it
and we don't have to rehash that whole
thing this is kind of a part of
i guess her argument is like if you're
that close to someone seeing them all
the time you know you have that much
chemistry with them like it's risky for
your actual relationship
which then ties into like the main point
of this episode which i want to talk
about was actual workplace affairs
so
i it's weird because like i felt like i
had a work husband before
and like but i knew he was married and i
knew i would never do anything or ever
and you don't like
let them on to like that you have those
no yeah it's like you would never know
you would never know yeah okay what if
he let you know
then it would cross the line yeah yeah
then you have to like everybody
or something yeah yeah but like i guess
like specifically with your experience
because you're like already having sex
dreams of the dude and like really
exciting you're like no no what if he
actually approached you and was like hey
you know i've been feeling these strong
feelings i would just try to reassign
you yeah because i know he's married and
i wouldn't want to
it's like it's like once it's real i
don't want it yeah so
one time uh one one work husband um was
like oh we were done for the day we're
going to our cars and um he asked if i
wanted to smoke with him like smoke weed
and i was like no like no actually
outside activities no absolutely not um
going straight home like
after work it's done like and also at
work there's no lines being crossed like
there can't be any any of that but it's
just like an exciting like but we can do
anal at work but afterwards yeah
only on the clock
really quick we're going to take a quick
break and a shout out to our sponsor so
make sure you uh listen in and give them
some support and they're supporting our
show we love them thank you very much
everyone has a different feel about
online shopping some people like
in-person shopping some people freaking
hate it some people freaking hate online
shopping sometimes it can be daunting
you never know things will fit returns
are difficult you don't even know where
to start with your style exactly i am
this season let's stitch fix do all the
hard work okay stop stressing out
now they're introducing stitch fix
freestyle which is a shop built just for
you
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle whether
you're looking for a brand you love or
to try a new one at stitch fix freestyle
you can shop over a thousand brands
personalized to your size and fit
with styles for workout to work wear for
lounging and around the house or for a
night out stitch fix freestyle has
clothes for any occasion i don't want to
see your curated store so i can see what
kind of outfits i picked for you yeah
it's like this is the jess store it's
all very like covered wear and covered
up wetsuits i don't really i don't
really show my skin much
don't judge her stop
don't make fun of my skin okay anyways
plus there's no subscription required
with stitch fix freestyle they offer
free shipping returns and exchanges just
go check it out at least get started
today by filling out your style quiz at
stitchfix.com
big mood that's stitchfix.com bigmood to
try stitch fix freestyle stitchfix.com
big mood
check it out i like the style quiz
because like do you like jean jackets or
wetsuits
just like you know what
when you're young you young 18 and under
people out there it is very easy to
discount the importance of sleep quality
but as you get older you very much will
realize how much a good night's sleep
will affect your entire life if you're
sleeping on a terrible mattress your
sleep will be terrible it's that simple
that's why i personally recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress because
purple mattresses have the gel flex grid
it's a super stretchy ultra squishy
material that adapts and flexes around
pressure points and it doesn't retain
heat so if you're like a sweaty sleeper
don't worry about that we got a mattress
that does not retain heat you won't get
all uncomfortable waking up in the
middle of the night throwing the covers
off of you it's got that nice cooling
effect to it and also if you have like a
bad back or like you know you got you
got some sore points um that's what the
gel flex grid is there for it's it just
goes around that it doesn't you don't
need to be like you know stressed out in
your sleep the gel flex grid is
amazingly supportive for your back and
legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips so no matter how you sleep
if you sleep on your stomach your side
your back like a vampire i don't know
how people do that but i wish i could no
matter how you sleep you're gonna be
covered and unlike memory foam which
remembers everything the gel flex grid
purple mattresses bounce back as you
move and shift so you'll never have that
oh i'm stuck feeling that people get
with the memory foam you can also try
purple mattress risk free with free
shippings and returns and financing is
available too getting a great night's
sleep starts with having a great
mattress so get a purple mattress go to
purple.com
big mood 10 and use code big mood 10.
for a limited time you can get 10 off
any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
big mood 10 code big mood 10 for 10 off
any order of 200 or more
bigmood.com
big mood 10 promo code big mood 10 terms
apply and we're back hope you love those
sponsors
so i guess we can try to kind of start
getting in a little bit to this this um
so this was an article on huffington
post and it's called the psychology of
workplace affairs
um but what i found interesting was
there was this one paragraph let me see
affairs are not always about sex
although physical intimacy can be a huge
driver so i think that that's kind of
what tiff was getting on affairs are
more about creating a version of
yourself that's more appealing more
alive than the version that shows up in
your real life in your primary
relationship like a fantasy so it's it's
i think the fantasy part is what me and
nikki were trying to say like if it
really
if the guy started to try to make it a
move to make it happen then it would
shatter exactly the fantasy of like i
just like going to work and i just like
this person but then if it became real i
don't want it and that's the difference
between me having like a fake work
husband and actually having a real
affair yeah he's just like very serious
because even when i was like crushing on
steve like i would never let anything
happen like that would never happen
not in one million years because what
one thing i liked about him was that he
was so loyal to his girlfriend when he
like praised her all the time and i just
i would never ruin that ever we're not
just like then it would turn it would
like it was still your boner yeah
he's a disloyal person so he's not the
person that i but i feel like it's also
disgusting that he ever dated anyone
before you
it's pretty gross so i feel like you
should go start a fight well i made it i
blessed i i took his dick to a priest to
have it blessed
okay he don't he dunked his dick
i was gonna say you start an argument
right now
and we know why gina is still single and
i'm just kidding
same girl same thing
yeah
that's right yeah
i just thought about it
before you yeah greener was in someone
else before that's disgusting
so inconsiderate that's so ridiculous
um there is this this other thing this
is workplace affairs are often between
people who get to see each other shine
and succeed and this admiration or power
dynamic can fuel it there may be
workplace rules in place for bidding
such unions which only make it more
enticing and yet because they're not the
ones seeing their [ __ ] dirty
underwear yeah like i don't have to
[ __ ] pick up his socks i don't have
to [ __ ] clean his dirty dishes i
don't have to see his [ __ ] pube hairs
all over the bathroom
he's this polished he's wearing like
nice work clothes or whatever he's
always shaving he always smells good i'm
not getting the [ __ ] farting on a
saturday afternoon you see this is why
you don't fart or
[ __ ] in front of your partner that's
crazy though like so how do you have a
relationship for 20 30 years with
someone see all the worst of them
but then keep it keep it
no keep it a mystery like we've been
together almost a decade i've never
heard him fart he's never heard me
before like we you've never even seen
him completely
because we we have the same rule and
okay
we've like it's been accidental we're
like oh [ __ ] but not just some dude like
farting and belching on the couch like
all of my ex-boyfriends all of them
would literally be like
lift up their legs
dude
just like hit that rule i was like
number
and everyone does that and all my
boyfriends said that too and i dated all
comedians and
they all like you know they're dude
dudes um but it surprised me that steve
had that role and oh steve implemented
it was his rule yeah i i was like really
you don't feel like farting in front of
your person makes it like you guys are
comfortable in front of each other he's
like nope i knew a guy that was married
for a long long time and he told me that
was his secret yeah to keep it a mystery
and i always took that with me and i'm
like it's [ __ ] true because i still
have just as much if not more sexual
attraction to him than ever yeah i see
before i mean uh before tiff and
hypothetically because you've never been
with anyone before
um
did you ever fart in whatever in front
of your significant other yeah he said
yeah very open with all that stuff but i
i do value not
farting he's he's now yeah now he's not
beneficial i would die you have to get
remarried you'll never fart in front of
her
i guess it depends on that person but no
he won't because we'll kill her yeah we
will kill her kill her
wait so it depends on that person
because like you know how like steve for
example he's he was like no this is a
hard rule because it's going to kill the
romans it's for the relationship you
don't see it that way at all you
specifically i'm the person oh okay what
about for you though so tiff ripped a
big fat one you would be like that's hot
he's hot but it's like i think he would
be face it's indifferent
i honestly thought you would have said
yes because you're weird
i honestly feel like deep down inside
you care but the surface part because
that's easier to get to you just say i
don't care and you don't really do
psychoanalysis
i've been with you for a decade i'm like
you actually do care about a lot of [ __ ]
you just don't say it are you gonna are
you gonna look when the baby cries
the baby
you're gonna lose
you can just see it when it takes its
first breath yeah yeah i mean you can
see it like from here probably but not
like the full frontal beautiful nelson
no no
no
preserve the image of your woman's voice
as much as you can why don't you just
record it so like later when you're old
and yeah you don't want to [ __ ] her
anyway then you can watch it later and
be like oh that's what happened
wait until she's like 50 or 60 when you
guys are barely so because of his answer
to say yes that he's down to see the
baby crowning when i'm giving birth i
for sure would have thought he would
have said yeah i would think that's hot
when she's farting yeah because he's
it's hot just indifferential for the
baby
yeah he just wants to see what it really
is yeah i wasn't saying that the baby
thing is sexual is just like that's how
disgusting he tends to be yeah okay well
i mean he's just a man so yeah just
baseline disgusting yeah because like
i'll be like oh man this is the first
time i actually smell my bo now that i'm
pregnant oh [ __ ] and then he's like oh
let me smell i'm like no
you guys are weird yeah so you guys are
super weird steve does the same thing he
also likes smelling my head that's yeah
hardcore
do you like it better when she sweats
too like yes he loves it
like right after the treadmill he wants
to like smell my head yeah this guy's
the same that is very strange
i don't think we are like that
i like we are about to like the armpit
area on guys like you can rest your head
on that i like that [ __ ] if they have if
they have uh
on
but so okay so how does that change the
workplace you know like because how
we're talking about how guys are like
they're more polished at work we don't
see like the shitty sides yeah
you know it's higher propensity to have
a crush on them because like we're not
seeing all of them
how do you think that plays in i guess
because i've never worked in nine to
five like i can't really relate to this
part because um
like steve and i work together all the
time so i don't have that but the times
that i've worked on like a film or
something like that it's more just like
a it's less of a they're more polished
and more of a like oh that's a different
flavor like i've i've been not i haven't
interacted with this flavor before yeah
but you know when i picture them and the
reason i don't go home and like
fantasize about them is because
those people they're usually like kind
of funny but they don't seem like
mature
husband guys like i would never like
that doesn't seem like your industrial
relationship your industry it's just
like a different like yeah oh that's a
different
taste
okay what i think i can relate it to a
little bit where you're saying about the
whole like polished version of it and
then like someone can be attracted to
that and then like it could lead to a
fair kind of thing i think it's the same
kind of psychology when
people are like they know so much about
like a celebrity or a youtuber oh right
yeah like they fully know their whole
life and they feel a strong connection
because then they're relating it to
their own life even though they've never
actually met and they don't see the bad
they don't see it yeah they don't see
any of the bad parts it's all polishing
a full picture yeah
i could see i could see how
that can play into like a work setting
yeah and then because they actually have
the added
layer of having that interaction and
actually like communicating and like
connecting on a deeper level yeah
there this article is talking about how
people um can feel alone and depleted in
their relationships because like when
you don't have the same job or like even
in the same industry you don't like when
you come home
what you did for eight or ten hours that
was stressing you the [ __ ] out like they
don't they're not gonna understand it at
all so i think in like a part of human
nature is like you just really want to
be understood
you like the camaraderie so like
it's risky when you spend then eight to
ten hours with someone who understands
the like they're a part of your daily
mission
like that's if you think about it like i
like i'm like i'm going to work with an
accountant yeah
they're going to do exactly what i do
no commiserating with some [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] on some [ __ ] you're doing you know
like i think that's another thing yeah
because like i can only speak from like
projects i've worked on but it's like
you're both working on the same project
yeah the same goal that your partner
wouldn't understand the project at all
and then so you go home and you like
want to explain or yeah you just like
want them to understand but they're like
i don't get it that makes sense i've
only dated like uh a couple guys in the
gaming industry and it does make it a
lot more fun when they understand yeah
and you have something to talk about
after work and stuff freaking crazy all
right uh to i mean get rid of the risk
of this i say we segregate workplaces
buy sexes
wait what about same-sex couples and
what about bi oh sorry bisexual
orientation
okay so there's just like a thousand
different
offices for the same thing it's true
that's true all the buys
you know i'm just going to go into my
man's work every once in a while fire
off a few rounds
just come into his office put your pants
down take a piss in the lobby no
work for heterosexuals though like or i
mean yeah
like put all the bi people in one as i
say
all right he's only allowed to work with
old geriatric people my husband will be
in a cage yeah and everyone else is
whatever they want yeah okay
what if he has a thing for geriatric
people he doesn't discover it until he's
working with them damn it okay then i
don't want to be with him i'm good i'm
out i don't know i don't want to set the
poke holes in every single solution he's
like hey before we have sex can you draw
wrinkles on you oh
can you do this with your lips i mean
that granny porn exists for a reason i
guess so i was trying to think like if
steve had this on like you know i had a
what if he had like a crypto girlfriend
yeah i don't know
i don't
him in particular like all my other
boyfriends no [ __ ] them they're dead but
i i don't i trust him so much and even
now when he said like looking back on
our old when we were just friends um in
relationships he said that he felt the
same way about me but i would never know
like and he didn't know that i felt that
way either so like we don't let anyone
see that and so i don't think that he
would ever cross the line either and in
that and that makes me feel safe so i
don't really mind and i don't think he
has that but if he did yeah as long as
i'm happy he's not going to act on it
you know
that's why you're married to him exactly
and then also i felt like i forgot to
add this part when i felt these things
i'd come home and i'd want to be with
him more
you know like it kind of gives you you
know
that energy it's like you get a dopamine
serotonin kind of brush and then that
fuels the rest of your day so like for
me that like when i have a crush on
someone like i'll work out more i'll
like eat better like like it's the
chemicals that that
that environment's giving me that caused
me to be better as like yeah in my own
life even though like i don't want to be
with that person or anything but they're
giving me kind of like yeah the
chemicals the feel-good chemicals by
just having that exciting
relationship keeps you on point yeah all
areas and it's not necessarily for them
but they're just yeah the they're the
catalyst yeah they're for some reason
delivering me serotonin and dopamine in
my brain yeah but i don't want it to
like i don't want to like [ __ ] create
a life with this person no i don't want
him to divorce his wife now like that's
just crazy like you don't want the mess
involved you're just like oh it's just a
light thing as long as it stays the same
it should be fleeting it shouldn't get
deeper and deeper and deeper i just
remembered about this person that
reached out to me and he's like hey i
need some advice he was
working at a grocery store um he was
also like 20 years old like freshly 20
years old and he's like i'm hooking up
with my coworker and she was like 40
something oh my god or 40 something
she was double she was married
and with kids and then he's like what
should i do i was like you [ __ ] leave
dude what the hell uh stop [ __ ] her
yeah exactly and then
he was like yeah but i don't know and
then
next thing you know like a couple what
was he questioning though he's like what
do you mean
she said that she would leave her
husband for me and i was like oh he was
like how do i get out of this no he
he wanted to stay yeah do you think
she'll really leave him i'm like no
and even if she does do you really want
to be with someone like that you know
like twice his age yeah this woman
should be dropping you off at school if
anything you know
so then a couple weeks later he hits us
up he's like hey you know thank you guys
for all the advice but i think i'm still
gonna pursue this and i know it's gonna
be disappointing to you guys but
i have no idea where he is well it's his
life and his choice i don't ever
recommend
breaking into marriage i can't i can't
relate to the whole workplace affairs
part yeah cause i
i just don't think that's not to me
that's not fun anymore that's not what
it was about yeah but then that logic
too of like going back to that story
like how he wants to stay and be with
someone who would do this to someone
else that they once yeah
that they had a whole marriage and
probably kids i don't know
i don't understand that she's probably
going to die of old age by the time you
turn 21 to drink bro like do you think
it's probably
do you think it's probably like a
a form of narcissism like a conquest
where he's like
i i'm the special one yeah i get two
they ruined their whole [ __ ] [ __ ]
that they had going on for me because i
definitely have heard girls in that
situation yeah have that mentality i had
a
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that are like oh like he's gonna
leave his wife for me yeah it's going to
be great i can take her man if i want to
yeah
legit i had a friend like that who was
the other woman and she was like she
would get so like
mad at the girl like because she like
his girlfriend that he was living with
would show up in his instagram pictures
and she would get so mad at her like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] like she's so old and
blessed and like i'm like you're the one
like
breaking up this yeah like it's so it
was so gross to me that is really gross
and then um and then he ended up like so
she found the girlfriend found out
and he didn't leave his girlfriend for
her yeah he got dumped and then he was
like hooking up with my friends still
until he found another girl
yeah it you were never yeah she thought
she was though yeah or there'll be
situations where same situation where he
gets dumped because he got caught
cheating and then he ends up with a side
girl and then he gets with the side girl
but then he ends up having another
second yeah yeah like it's just a chain
yeah like i'm a these are not believers
like tutors will never yeah
yeah once a cheater always a cheater
yeah
so i i did there's another article that
i was looking at too and it was talking
about why people that are in happy
relationships cheat because i feel like
that kind of ties in huh
is it because they feel like they don't
deserve their relationship well there's
sabotage there's like a list of things
here where people said this is why that
they cheated even though they still
even though they're in a happy
relationship and they'll and they don't
want to get divorced right it's
interesting so um there's a few let's
see let me pick some good ones um so the
cheater thinks that all sexual
attraction must lead to action oh so i
guess that's some sort of
kind of a faulty thinking
where this person believes well if i'm
sexually attracted to them i should like
see it to the end even though i love my
wife i don't want to leave my wife
that's weird yeah i can see okay if if
you if you're one of those people then
you need to seek a partner that's
willing to have an open relationship
yeah yeah because that's what that's
what people in open relationships are
like they're like i love you
sex is different and sex is just like
can be shared and there's no feelings
involved but yeah that's uh i i couldn't
imagine doing that it would wreck me
like from within to know that i did that
to my partner yeah i and just the
thought of every person that i find
sexually attractive i must pursue until
the end that sounds tiring dude oh yeah
what the hell well i i mean personally
i'm not that
i don't have that many people that i
come across in life that i'm sexually
attracted to so if i guess if one came
out of every five years i might think
like oh i should pursue this because
it's rare right i mean obviously i don't
i would never cheat on anyone but i'm
trying to get into the mindset of
someone who feels like they should
pursue
a sexual attraction because it wouldn't
be exhausting for me because that like
rarely happens like rarely does it
happen that i'm like oh i actually want
to sleep with this person
so maybe that's where they're at like
it's not a like every six weeks there's
a new
you know person that they're totally
down for
i also wonder what these people's
definition of a happy relationship is
like because sometimes i meet people and
they're like oh yeah we have a great
great relationship but they mean that
they work well together almost like a
business like they
uh com like one person does these tasks
this person does this test the finances
are together everything is together but
there's no passion or sexual it's a
transaction exactly but they're like no
no we're very stable you know and they
think that's equals a happy relationship
weird i read i read a reddit post where
this guy admitted and he was like
uh the reason why my wife
and i's relationship works out so well
is because i cheat on her at least she's
once or twice a year yeah so he was like
yeah we heard a bunch of those once or
twice a year i go on a business trip and
you know i sleep
treating her better because it's
actually guilt underneath that yeah and
you're making it like
he's absolutely fueled by guilt yes yeah
yeah so he's like and it makes my wife
happy because she gets all these nice
things and people are like dude you're a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and by like her
thinking he's a great guy so he's
validated like see i can't be that bad
if she thinks something the only way
this could be acceptable is if the
wife's in on it exactly only way and
then it's not cheating
open relationships yeah exactly well and
then another one of the reasons
obviously is um this is just preference
but people some people believe that sex
can be
separated from love which i guess that's
that's why there's there's some of those
poly relationships right where they're
just open um or that they don't know
differently i'm like how is this one
this well so um some people see cheating
as a normal part of all relationships a
learned behavior they've copied from
parents family or past relationships
this person said i don't plan to go down
the whole freudian route but if a
cheater has ever seen parents or peers
steer away from a committed relationship
into a sexual
affair with another thing they just
think that's normal yeah so i mean we've
heard some people that are like well
everyone's just going to cheat yes
everyone cheats like everyone cheats
like so they they don't know that that's
not necessarily
real or legit bad for people that really
believe that or that like yeah that's
just a thing like there's no option my
husband's gonna cheat no matter what so
it's fine damn
i guess if you're like okay with
accepting that it like
the one time that that happened to me i
was like devastated
i could never cheat on somebody
my uh the girlfriend that i always tell
you guys about the sex worker she's
dealt with so many men
that she's super jaded now which is
crazy because now she's like a crystal
healer kind of person that does readings
you people are shaming interesting
crystal people yeah she's those crystal
people um but then working in the sex
industry for so long she's like gina
every man cheats it's just it's just the
way it is i was like dude that's a
really cool also her industry draws yeah
yeah like exactly
what it's exactly all in the sex
industry yeah if your job is to study
car crashes you're like every car every
car is
yeah
it's a really sad way to think you know
yeah just very now it's like i feel like
you're
pessimistic with every relationship you
go in yeah i mean i get it though it's
definitely easy to feel like
when it feels like 80 percent of men
would then you're just like
good luck with the other prophecies yes
yeah
your friend i mean me obviously yeah
yeah
that's what everyone says everyone in
the comments always
i'm at the point where i'm like [ __ ]
come into our podcast so we can just
settle this right now
it's her okay yeah that's funny we could
have crystal showings together casey i
think you met her no
oh no this was early early jk because jk
like bart and jonathan after she met
casey would she like every man cheats
meant bart and jill every man cheats oh
[ __ ] wait no that might be before casey
anyways um another reason why someone
said um people may succumb to the lure
of something exciting and novel even if
they're otherwise happy
so um
basically they were just bored even
though they still love them they i still
like there's nothing intrinsically wrong
just getting bored and i'm like how do
you feel
comfortable getting married knowing that
someone could just get bored and i'm
like oh it's so scary
i think it's their personality too like
yeah i think that's what it reflects in
other ways too if this person needs to
have a new car every like yeah yeah well
i need a new car every couple years what
does that say about me you can get more
people i'm never marrying you
or like you just like for me it's like
oh [ __ ] someone that's on a diet and
they're just quick to cheat on the diet
right oh what like how else are you
viewing the rest of your commitment and
discipline exactly yeah and like exactly
the commitment and discipline it's like
you're down to cheat on your on your
diet you want something new every five
minutes you don't take care of what you
do have because it's like i [ __ ] i'll
just get something else i'm like
that kind of like show signs of yeah
right possibly yeah exactly lifestyle
reckless doesn't care to take care of
anything or tear [ __ ] or make it last at
all and it's just quick to just toss it
and
have no value on anything yeah
like you could easily see a relationship
like that totally
i think also like
it's people that haven't
like found their thing like they're not
passionate about something so they yeah
they're looking for these dopamine
rushes in other places all the time and
nothing's ever satisfying that because
it's so
fleeting um whereas like you know for
example with steve he's obsessed with
crypto he's on there all the time i
don't have to worry about him getting
years like he's been here doing that for
years obsessed with it unless he's like
secretly talking to a webcam girl yeah
i've like done laundry and like come in
his office and he's always looking at
charts it's so boring
really quick we need to take another uh
sponsor break to shout out the people
supporting the show so give them your
attention buy it buy something buy
something that's how you support us
all right so you guys know i have two
wonderful kitties at home that our
family absolutely loves and have loved
them for the past eight years they're
they bring so much joy to our family but
what we don't really love is the stink
bombs that they leave in their litter
box everything from cleaning to covering
up the smell
has always been a constant battle but
not anymore ever since we started using
pretty litter we've been using pretty
litter for quite some time now and we're
thoroughly happy with pretty litter
because it is kitty litter reinvented
unlike traditional litter pretty litters
super light crystals trap odor and
release moisture resulting in dry low
maintenance litter that doesn't smell
and pretty litter is virtually dust free
because it's manufactured with a
specialized d-dusting process
pretty litter arrives safely at my door
in a small lightweight bag that lasts up
to a month
and now i get litter bags auto shipped
so i don't have to deal with last minute
trips to the store and shipping is free
but above all else here's why pretty
litter is a parent's hero it is a health
indicator pretty litter monitors my
cat's health by changing colors when it
detects potential underlying issues
you will not find that kind of
innovation in conventional litter
so get the world's smartest litter
without leaving your home by visiting
prettylitter.com and using promo code
big mood for 20 off your first order
that's pretty litter.com promo code big
mood for 20 off
pretty litter.com promo code big mood
bonjour my lovelies whether it's saving
more and spending less getting organized
or losing weight there's a lot of
worthwhile goals to set yourself up for
this year at the top of my list is
learning a new language with babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions and if you
hadn't guessed yet the language that i'm
trying to currently learn is french and
i've got to say i really really enjoy
the babel app compared to others i've
tried pretty much all of the ones on the
market over the last six years and babel
is my favorite for the kind of quick
style on the go 15 minute lessons that
you can do after dinner or you know
while you're taking a bath or whatever
babel really is a great great user
interface and i love the way the lesson
plans are set up and i feel like i'm
really actually getting some of these
words sticking in my brain babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use their 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts with babble
you can choose from 14 different
languages including spanish french
italian and german there are so many
ways to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now when you purchase a three-month
babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use promo code big
mood that's b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com code mood babble language for
life and we're back did you buy it
um okay so i wanted to also touch on
like
there i found this other article the
worst thing you can say after cheating
on someone but i want to see if you guys
can guess it wait to get away with you
no we're not getting away with anything
this is just like interpersonal things
like you have to okay
the worst thing you could say okay
they gave better head
oh yeah don't say the person's better
than them yeah in any way uh what about
i know what people always say it didn't
mean anything yeah is that one of you
yeah because so you threw away a
relationship for somebody that's for
nothing yeah
i don't think there's anything they
could say that makes it it's not about
making it
this is just literally how like this is
what makes it makes it worse yeah yeah
don't like like nothing's gonna make it
okay ever like nothing you could say
will like make that okay or better
better so would it be a little bit
better if they cheated on you with
someone and it's like i'm sorry but i
really am in love with this person like
it's this is who i want to be with and
then they actually end up spending the
rest of their lives together does that
make it a little bit better i mean in 40
years like
40 years later you might be like okay
well yeah i guess they really found
their one but in the moment and for like
the whole [ __ ] life like no that's
going to succeed you can't make it
better but so 40 years later does that
make it feel a little bit better than it
would have been if it was yeah it meant
nothing probably i really didn't think
it depends on the person because a
person could see it that way that's
receiving it or it's like well that's
good good for them like oh they were
meant to be but then the other like a
different person could be like oh my god
like i wasn't good enough and like they
met that caliber and i couldn't yeah
that's wonderful too but also like you
don't want to
be like the person that's wrong for the
you know like you don't want to be
married to someone like you're not being
friends like it's hard it's a hard pill
to swallow
but then i think that's why i'm saying
just like with time like later on you'll
be like okay you know that wasn't that
wasn't really about me no matter what
i'm out of 10 already so yeah say the
worst thing because you can't get worse
i think for me personally like the worst
worst worst
would be for them to deny it okay yeah
that that's yes the
and then they get mad at me for finding
out mm-hmm and then they throw it at me
like how dare you crazy
yeah
that would be like it's like cheating's
here and then that would make it like
that's what happened to me like i had to
message the girl and i was like yo i
might be i might sound so crazy but this
isn't the first time and i just let me
know so i could let this person yeah
yeah she was nice enough to let me know
that yeah i was right and it made me
feel so much better because this guy was
insulting me that i actually like he
thought i was crazy or used to call me
crazy i didn't have the the guy
insulting me that i was crazy i had the
guy saying she's [ __ ] nuts like why
do you think i would touch her she's
like
yeah so i would never be the attacked
one for finding out but it was like why
would i be with her she's gross you're
always on my arm over in public like
you're the you know like why would i
[ __ ] touch this every network knows
about you yeah so i'm just like okay
yeah okay so that he tried that he did
that first and yeah i feel better but
then i kept seeing her name pop up in
his phone yeah and so that i'm like this
isn't insulting to my intelligence if
you're at this point telling me that
there's nothing else going on and why
did you put a lock on your phone after
you already had no lock on your phone
it's just weird like all these little
things i don't know yeah and i'm like
this isn't my first rodeo and he was
like you're actually crazy because i
can't even believe that you still don't
believe me
and i was like i'm not dealing with you
anymore and then i then i messaged her
on facebook because that was what
everyone used at the time yeah and i was
just like i feel
crazy and the one thing i knew about her
is that she had just gotten cheated on
with her boyfriend and he gave her an
std and that was one of the things that
he my boyfriend was saying was that like
i wouldn't touch her she has an std so
like why would i why would i do that
like that wouldn't touch it with a
10-foot pole and did you find out that
she had an std through him yeah because
he could have just made that up oh true
like you could just be like but you know
how larry's used part truth so i'm like
at least if she doesn't have that i
think she did just get broken up with
her boyfriend or i mean no cd part or
just get cheated on by her well stds are
very rampant so it's not out of the
question yeah it's probably true boy
isn't it
sure it is well so this article is um
saying an affair wasn't about the their
partners painful because it's hard to
think that you weren't even on your
partner's radar when you made that
decision it makes a person feel unwanted
unloved and unimportant wait saying yes
saying that like it's not about you it's
like whatever so they're saying to be
better if it was a revenge g no i think
it's just like the fact that you didn't
even think about me like
like it's
i get it what was the sentence itself
okay saying an affair wasn't about
you oh it wasn't you it's somebody it's
excruciating to think you weren't even
you weren't on your partner's radar when
they made that decision it makes you
feel
of
unwanted
and
drunk situation i could see that
probably come up or something where it's
like i was drunk like i just didn't
realize like that that was like it got
to that point and then i mean it could
be a tiny little bit more forgivable
because alcohol can do that but still
like the point is that i was so
unimportant that even in your most
drunken state you didn't even think
about me kind of thing like i guess that
could be like an example of what this
means yeah yeah this goes on to say
unfaithful partners say things like that
because it's true it may be hard to
believe but when most people cheat they
really aren't thinking about their
spouse at the time they're thinking with
their groins their hormones their
emptiness or their insatiable sense of
attraction
saying it meant nothing comes across as
i destroyed your world for nothing
right and if they said they did think
about you i feel like that's a lie like
if they said like yeah that's because
you never do blah blah blah like they're
they're trying to blame it on you
i think that's a lie i remember the
my first big relationship he cheated on
me multiple times um i took him back the
first time stupidly and then the second
time that he cheated on me because i i
only found out about two it turns out
there was like a [ __ ] ton yeah but the
second time i found out he was like
his excuse was well you were always
going to not trust me anyways from last
time and you were going to accuse me of
myself as well yeah i was like what the
[ __ ] are you out of your mind dude yes
he is out of this he is fine what are
other things that make it hard um
well i think i mean this whole article
is basically just expounding on like the
the whole like saying it meant nothing
like it's basically like this is
probably the worst way to go about it so
i think it's more like try to figure out
what really
was going
i mean i don't know it's like because
people initially just want to be like oh
it's not you like i don't you know like
i i wasn't even thinking about you like
it's it's not even you know like it may
be in an attempt to make it like better
better like hurt less like it's not your
fault
i wasn't even thinking it was so stupid
well that's shitty because then on the
other hand they would the person i got
chewed on be like and so i didn't even
do anything wrong and you you're
punishing me i feel like like
they're just taking on like i'm stupid
it was like
you know is this for people that still
want to um save their relationship i
guess like if you were trying to salvage
a relationship then
maybe you care about this but for me if
my partner cheated like it doesn't any
excuse we'll do it i don't give a [ __ ]
what you say after that like after i
find out it's done like no coming back
from it there's no like bridge there's
nothing for you this is gone you don't
know what i said i'm like what is
because that's me too yeah that's it you
[ __ ] up heart this is unforgivable
yeah that's it you crossed the line
shattered it can never put it back
together but um what i was thinking of
though because like i have heard of
situations where
that does happen in their relationship
and like one person's cheating and then
they'll end up still figuring it out
yeah but that's my exact but then that
re but then the reason that is brought
up it's like
i cheated because you didn't give me
attention
and it's like
[ __ ] like for if i heard that i'm like
well why didn't you say anything you
[ __ ] like yeah i don't know like to me
what if they had said something would
that make it different like if they had
been voicing their
uh yeah i guess that night's not being
met then at that point then i could feel
like
okay i like this is my role in this
i could take accountability for like
what led to this
um
and but you still didn't have to cheat
on
the cheating part me
like you should you jump the gun like
you should have said we need to go to
therapy or i want a divorce yeah that's
not to me like i said it's unforgivable
yeah at least that would be better than
hearing like this stuff like this excuse
me you get a heads up at least yeah
knowing what led to it exactly when you
saw like it in motion
yeah where it's like okay like this is
the role that i played we are not going
to fix this it's unfixable but at least
i know what happened and at least like
there's um yeah like there was like
there was a route instead of just like i
don't know i didn't think of it like you
didn't cross my mind it was just for the
moment or whatever it was it meant
nothing
or if it's like yeah i didn't
communicate to you at all but you
weren't giving me attention and this
other person was and i just ended up
having
like a thing with that person for a
while even though we were together and
not saying placing the blame thing is
like really kind of [ __ ] up yeah
yeah this article is talking about that
they said usually when someone says like
you know i didn't mean it didn't mean
anything whatever the cheating partner's
trying to show that they never intended
to leave the spouse and kids for the
affair but it's um minimizing
thing to say hey i cheated on you but it
could be worse um what they're saying is
you have to admit that you understand
that your selfish actions cause you and
your spouse incredible pain you're the
sole architect of this shitty situation
but i don't know like there's all of
these like couples therapists and stuff
that are like trying to like write
articles and books on like how to like
get through this stuff because it's like
we can't just keep throwing away
divorces over
stuff like that and yeah you know like
yeah it's it's hard for me to
have a like a strong opinion on what's
right or wrong about cheating
because i just feel like if you have a
partner and you go all the way through
marriage
like the fact that you actually went
through the marriage should mean like
it's my responsibility and your
responsibility before either of us does
anything to tear it apart that we
first say we need therapy we need yeah
attention yes and for you to fail in
saying we need therapy we need attention
before something destructive destructive
occurs means like you're not a part of
this marriage yeah you never work i
don't care about that so like why why do
i need to save it why do i need to go
through yeah it's not it's tough though
because then if there's kids
then you have to break up the family i
can understand the tougher situation
when there's kids involved yeah um or if
like the woman never worked and she has
no income and no job history and now
she's like yeah [ __ ] up absolutely and
then especially um you know
traditionally when people got married
younger and they're they don't even know
who they are yet yeah and then their
identities completely grow apart like
where
they they're different people you know
and so
they don't realize like oh we weren't
actually in love that was just like a
first relationship and we got married um
instead they they're like oh i like this
person over here and they don't they're
not thinking about what they're doing i
can have some empathy for that but that
doesn't mean you stay together like you
have to stay together and work it out
after somebody like you stay together
you cheat and stay together yeah
i think divorces are actually a great
thing
because i mean yeah it's unfortunate it
happened but that means you two are
making strides to
find your own happiness you know and you
respect yourself and you both are
setting boundaries and yeah so you learn
from that experience yeah exactly so i
love those like divorce celebration
parties like that's cool like you guys
are celebrating together like you know
what we didn't work out and we're doing
what's best for us we'll sing harder
yeah yeah
and then i i so i i don't
whenever somebody says like oh i just
got divorced and people say oh i'm so
sorry i'm like oh dude that's cool yeah
yeah usually
even if it ended on bad terms that means
like they but i would say that's cool if
that's what they wanted to because then
no i mean even if it ended on bad terms
like oh i got a divorce because she
cheated on me he's like you know what it
sucks now but it's good for you yeah you
know for sure yeah um so my aunt and my
uncle are is
was in that kind of relationship high
school sweethearts
you know he like lost his virginity to
her like they were like this whatever
the huge couple he cheated on her and
then they ended up working it out and
they've been married for 20 something
years now so it's like well they started
so they started i mean i feel like i i
guess you kind of said that like i have
a little bit more
breathing room for people who are like
high school sweethearts that were
married like 50 60 years because i mean
imagine being a human
like in
only allowed to stay in one situation
for 60 years like that's hard to even
believe yeah so i can give a little bit
of empathy too yeah but and but that's
like one in a billion yeah yeah like
really so people hear those stories and
like well you know it could work out
like you're probably the rule not the
exception i'm sorry yeah yeah i don't
know i guess i kind of can't find
empathy yeah situation at all it's like
you made your decision you committed all
these years especially because of how
long it's been like what are you doing
yeah so i talked to my uncles like so
what what happened at the time because
they were high school sweethearts he
cheated on her how old was he when he
cheated uh i think like 19 or 20. yeah
that see that yeah i'm like he wasn't it
wasn't like 30 something you know so
it
uh
yeah if he was a grown man like at 45 i
would be like no this is [ __ ] up
exactly i mean a [ __ ] 20 year old kid
is an idiot yeah he was like you know
what i did it i regretted it and [ __ ]
it broke my heart
because she left me obviously and i
deserved it um and then i realized it
was the biggest mistake i ever made in
my life and they got back together but
again like this doesn't mean you guys
should do this yeah it's okay but that's
different because
that's what i'm saying like you're a kid
way different yeah just like then he
actually like saw
the like there was a realization there
was changes commitment there was like
trust building again and like all that
stuff and like
and then because of the young age i feel
like there's a lot of room to grow yeah
yeah like the older you are yeah and the
more like and then you're doing this
[ __ ] you know you want to try to fix it
now forever [ __ ] yeah sure you're
full on an adult no yeah yeah yeah i
mean after like 25 i'm kind of like 18
to 25 is when you learn all your lessons
yeah okay you gotta just [ __ ] that's
when you [ __ ] up and it's gonna hurt and
you're gonna get your knees scratched
but then you you grow up and you like
you get back up and you know how to
[ __ ] not hurt your knee anymore and
fall down and like you better just stay
on your feet there's no excuses for a
certain mistake like obviously we're all
humans and no one's perfect right so
even at 35 you can make mistakes but
there's certain things you should have
learned after 25 that's like it's
inexcusable like now i'm 35 and we're in
a relationship and you're going to cheat
now like you should have already known
that yeah this is not a thing you're
allowed it's not a mistake that's
forgivable at this age yeah and we i
mean that's i guess that's our opinion
there's other people that have different
opinions they're like well their
opinions are wrong but that's why
everything is personal uh personally for
me no no yeah deal breaker gun you don't
exist that's like you're setting the bar
too low yeah and when it comes to work
husbands and her work wives go in there
fire a few rounds off every few weeks
let them know you know just set your
yeah just bring in some cupcakes with
some one of them
one of them has arsenic good luck if i
had a work husband a work husband and
steve came around with a chocolate and
i'd be like oop that's kind of hard
to be like right he cares that much
we're toxic
we love the toxicity
everyone's getting fired up work right
from shooting you and then you for let
you knew yeah yeah and you didn't say
anything yeah and you for hiring her
yeah
anyway so i mean that's our hour yeah at
the end of the day cheating is always
wrong so don't [ __ ] do it and don't
accept it um wait can i extend a little
bit longer sure what if
she cheated because her husband was
beating the [ __ ] out of her that's
different yeah so that's the okay that's
the only thing she should she could do
but then she met a guy who's like like
dude you're gonna save her from it yeah
and then they fall in love in that case
i'd be like you know what yeah you're
fine you needed someone to rescue you go
go go go putting a carve out in a
contract right now like yeah so under
the circumstance that you are heavily
abused at home and then you meet a guy
that's going to rescue you no you can
show but you know how ridiculous it is
though like
like this is like society these days how
ridiculous it is you have to put those
exceptions in because then they're going
to be like keyboard warriors be like but
what about people that blah blah blah
blah so i get it no you don't need to
cheat because your husband's beating you
you need to [ __ ] get help yeah what
if that guy's helping her like hey you
can okay he helps yeah
[Laughter]
raiders five stars on itunes visit our
sponsors that's the number one way to
support the show second way to support
the show is just always come back and
watch yeah share with your friends
comment talk to you share with your work
husband yo
send this to the guy that you want to
cheat with
you don't cheat no cheating allowed
we're not kidding that's wrong stop it
i'm not kidding stop cheating stop it
the only time it's acceptable is if the
other party's aware and then at that
point it's not cheating cheating anymore
yeah it's cheat
for all the money here
bye
[Music]
you